good afternoon everybody
okay so
come on in guys
i have two housekeeping things and then
we'll get started
so we are excited to welcome olivia
dalton our new principal deputy press
secretary into the briefing room and uh
to our team olivia returns to the white
house after serving as the director of
communications and spokesperson at the
u.s mission to the united nations
olivia and i have known each other for
more than a decade right we've been
friends for more than a decade and so i
am very excited for her to join our team
and to be working with all of you as
well
and one other thing before we get
started
we wanted to continue our press team
tradition in the briefing room i just
want to take a moment to congratulate
and celebrate andrew he is getting
married this coming saturday continuing
that tradition come on guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
just wanted to say uh to add to that the
love he shares for his best friend movie
pal and partner megan apper is wonderful
uh we're wishing them the best as they
embark on a lifetime of love and
happiness
and uh and uh so of course like we have
done in the past
let's start this off right or finish
this off right little sasha
my friend
continuing the tradition we've got to
continue the tradition there you go let
it go oh am i doing this right
thank you
all right
[Laughter]
and
okay and one more thing and with that
there is a a special guest a surprise
guest for andrew in the briefing room
megan apper stand up there we go oh she
was right there
andrew did you see her
[Music]
[Laughter]
and megan
we're taking it to the next level here
and here's yours as well okay
all right
we take
marriage and wedding very seriously here
here on the pressing okay
congratulations guys we're so excited
for you
and i think
andrew's going to be gone for like 10
days right so don't bug him bug us
and uh really really excited for you and
congratulations to you thank you for
coming to surprise
okay
and right now
okay
okay
i do want to do that one day but no one
will take me up on it um but in all
seriousness okay so uh
we know you all had a couple of
questions on the ukraine counter
often offensive that they've been doing
the last uh week or so a couple of days
and so we wanted to invite our nsc
friend john kirby uh to come into the
briefing room and take a couple of
questions so i will let him do that he's
going to do about 15 minutes i think i'm
sure he has a topper and take a few
questions and of course we have the
event at three so we want to make sure
that we get to as many people as we can
today
go ahead all right
congratulations
there's no way what i'm about to say can
top that
i have uh two things i wanted to stop
with uh one is on pakistan and the other
uh armenian and azerbaijan quite frankly
and then i know there's going to be
questions on what's going on ukraine and
i'm happy to take those
uh but on pakistan
just a quick update on our assistance uh
or during this difficult time of
flooding and i think you've all been
seeing that and covering that the
devastation is pretty severe
33 million people
affected
1400
have died
almost 13 000 of an injured
infrastructure
literally washed away
to include almost 2 million homes
and
more than 4 million acres of farmland so
the united states continues to stand
with pakistan and the communities inside
pakistan and we'll help them as much as
we can i think you may have seen on
friday last week the usaid administrator
samantha power was in pakistan to meet
with flood affected communities and
during that visit she was able to
announce that the united states was
providing an additional 20 million
dollars in humanitarian assistance to
support the people of pakistan and that
brings to
53.1
million dollars a total of our support
this year just to support disaster
resilience
and flood response in pakistan with the
50 million for emergency flood relief uh
and and three
and resilience programming but it's not
just financial assistance and uh you'll
probably hear more about this from our
folks at the pentagon but
but yesterday a total of nine aircraft
run by u.s central command
[Music]
delivered more than 400 tons of relief
supplies to through usaid's dubai
warehouse in support again of the flood
response
and our assistance to the people of
pakistan is being determined of course
by u.s personnel on the ground usaid has
deployed a disaster assistance response
team to lead the u.s government's
humanitarian response efforts in
pakistan uh and again we're going to
continue to support them as much as we
can
on um
our armenian aish abraham some of you
have asked some questions about that i
think you probably saw our statement
yesterday the one that secretary blanken
issued we remain deeply concerned uh
about reports of continued attacks along
that border including reports of
shelling and significant damage to
civilian infrastructure
we're actively engaged
with both the armenian and the
azerbaijani government
uh to uh to see what we can do
to end this violence in fact secretary
blinken spoke with both the president of
azerbaijan overnight as well as the
prime minister of armenia we've long
said but it remains i think important
and it needs to be said again
that there can be no military solution
to this conflict we urge restraint from
any further military hostilities we also
encourage both governments to
re-establish direct lines of
communications across diplomatic and
military channels uh and to recommit uh
to a diplomatic process uh to resolve
the uh to resolve the crisis
steve is seeing a turning point in the
war in ukraine
i think what you're seeing is certainly
a shift in momentum by
uh by the ukrainian armed forces
particularly in the north now we've been
talking about this uh for quite some uh
days now this long planned counter
offensive it's really too counter
offensive steve we've got one in the
north and one in the south
clearly we've been watching closely and
the events in the north are
[Music]
more dramatic than what we've seen in
the south
i would let president zielinski
determine and decide
whether he feels uh militarily they've
reached a turning point but clearly
at least in the donbas the the there's a
sense of momentum here by the ukrainian
armed forces and so what we're going to
do is continue to support them as best
we can feel like the russians are just
turning tail and run or running
what are the russians doing here well
i'm i want to be careful not to speak
for a foreign military but i mean uh
certainly in the north we have seen
russians evacuate withdrawal retreat
from
their defensive positions particularly
their uh
in and around the the kharkiv oblast
they have left uh they've left fighting
positions they've left uh supplies uh
they have they have they're calling it a
repositioning but it's certainly they
have withdrawn uh in the face of
ukrainian armed forces that are clearly
on the offense
um but steve it's um i mean obviously
these are some dramatic events we're
watching but it's war and war is
unpredictable and i think we're gonna
watch this as closely as we can but it's
really the ukrainian armed forces that
um that should speak to the to the
progress they're making okay we got to
get out of here 235 so let me do that
uh what early signs are u.s seeing of a
russian response to the counteroffensive
and what fears do you do you and your
western allies have for how putin now
that he's taking these defeats uh may
escalate things further
good question so you've already seen
over the weekend the russian military
hit some infrastructure targets in
ukraine looks like they were largely
going after the power grid
mixed success i think not all their uh
strikes uh
hit the targets uh or at least damaged
the infrastructure to a maximum degree
but that was certainly what we would
anticipate or what we
analyzed as a response to what the
ukrainians were doing
up in the north it remains to be seen uh
what their next steps are going to be
here as the ukrainians remain on the
offense up in the north
and uh and to continue to pursue a
counter-offensive down in the south
um
they were invaded they have a right to
defend their country and their
territorial integrity and that means
going on the offense it doesn't mean
just defending uh and jonathan that i
know everybody's focused
rightly so on what we've been seeing the
last few days but i think it's important
to remember that even from the get-go
here but we back in february uh in march
uh the ukrainians were still on the
offense as well as on the defense in
this war
and uh it's a very dynamic situation
is there any concern that the that
russian repositioning would include
repositioning in armenia because of the
response we have not seen that uh and
now
what we want to see what we want to see
is the hostility stop um now the
russians apparently brokered a ceasefire
overnight that was almost immediately
broken um so
obviously we want to see there be a
ceasefire that that can stay in effect
um but uh but we haven't seen any
indication that russian forces are
repositioning now i will remind and i
think you know this i mean they did have
a peacekeeping presence there and as far
as we know that peacekeeping presence is
still there couple more
thanks john um
the u.s and allies have
taken the careful consideration kind of
the dynamics on the ground as they've
considered new support for assistance to
send to the military have your current
state of play changed or shifted what
type of capabilities the u.s is willing
to send to ukraine in this moment i
won't get ahead of future
security assistance packages i do think
you'll see another one here in coming
days phil uh we're in lockstep with the
ukrainians talking to them every day
secretary austin just held another
contact group last week with 50 some odd
countries and of course the ukrainians
were were present so there's real-time
discussions going on with ukrainians
about what their military needs are and
i would also add that many of the
systems that we've been providing in
just the last few weeks and a couple of
months have proven instrumental and
effective
in the ukrainian's ability to to go on
the offense and to be actually quite
effective on the defense uh in the last
several days and weeks to include of
course those advanced rocket systems
that were that we've talked about so
much they're using they're using them
with great effect
thank you very much
um
two questions please uh
there's been some pretty unprecedented
expressions in public by various
officials in russia
whether it's khadirov or some of the
municipal um uh elected officials
um discontent with what's going on um
even if they're coming from different
directions is there any indications that
putin faces a threat to his two decades
in power i think that's going to be up
to the russian people to decide i mean
we have uh taken note of of uh
uh
public statements by public officials um
and certainly it's not not insignificant
it's not the kind of thing you've
typically seen
mr putin has tried to obscure the
war in ukraine since
it started actually i'd go so far as to
say before it started calls it a special
military operation it's a war and he
hasn't been honest with his own people
about what he's doing there why he's
doing it and what he's doing it with and
he certainly hasn't been honest with the
russian people uh about the struggles
that the russian military have had in
the conduct of this war to include
casualties and losses of equipment and
systems
so
yeah we note that he's he's coming under
more criticism but it's going to really
be up to the russian people to decide
how they handle that another question
was is is what's happening around
nagorno-karabakh and in armenia is this
azerbaijan taking advantage
of the fact that russians are in a real
mess on the other side of that country
it's difficult for us to say with
certainty what the motivation is here as
you know
this has been these tensions have been
long running since the end of the soviet
union and broke out into full-scale war
in 2020. so it's really difficult to
know what uh you know what was the lit
match here that that started this uh
it's possible uh that there could be
some notion by some leaders that you
know russia's preoccupied but again i
think we need to be careful uh
speculating on that
yeah i wanted to ask you um chinese
investors were the most active buyers of
us real estate last year among
foreigners often paying cash for farms
homes above market rates many cases
pushing american buyers out of the
markets
at the same time housing is
becoming a crisis there is increasing
number of homelessness in the united
states black ownership
of homes is below what it was in the
1970s i'm wondering
given the fact that
known adversary in the case china
foreign buyers are
buying up u.s real estate in some case
farms around military installations this
is on the
administration's radar and what is being
done perhaps to study this or to protect
americans from making sure that homes
remain affordable
and so on i think the question of home
ownership is a little bit out my out of
my swim lane but
particularly when it comes to
around military installations what i
will tell you is that
the president has been
uh nothing but clear about our concerns
about chinese uh unfair trade practices
and economic practices
i pray i understand that ma'am
security and buying up land around
military installations i'm i'm probably
not the right person to ask about
homeownership here in the united states
this is about buying up land around
military installations is that a concern
to this administration
they've had a week to look at this
including the articles
we can get back to you afterwards we're
going to move on
thank you john two questions um going
back to your comments about the
struggles that russia is having with
this war
does that change the mindset the global
mindset about the perceived status of
russia being a superpower
with their struggles as you just said in
this war
i think you know look no further than
how the defense department has
characterized russia they they've talked
about russia being an acute threat and i
think that's a
accurate way of putting it um
they
clearly still have um
uh uh a military capable of inflicting
great damage and casualties and we've
seen that sadly
uh to some effect uh in ukraine uh now
clearly and i've talked about this many
times uh they have not
[Music]
they have not
overcome
struggles and challenges with respect to
command and control logistics and
sustainment unit cohesion integration of
air and ground i mean they've they have
met
with
many problems of their own making in
ukraine there's no question about that
but it's still a very large and very
powerful military and mr putin still has
an awful lot of military capacity left
at his disposal
not just to to be used in ukraine but
but potentially elsewhere
and the second question last question
on domestic national security issues um
benny thompson
the chair of house homeland
security committee
he said that water insecurity in this
nation is a national security threat you
have jackson mississippi
you had baltimore maryland just recently
flint michigan we're told is no better
than what it was it may even be worse
there are other
places around this nation
that are facing water issues
what do you say
about the
comment that water insecurity in this
nation is a national security threat
could you explain it i i think you know
april writ large uh
issues of of
resource security around the world uh
ends up affecting our national security
um and certainly the united states is
not immune to
the the problems that uh that are caused
either through infrastructure
needs or through climate change
but
in general when
when the country or any country faces
famine flood
drought
um or natural disaster it can create
security issues that
the united states military sometimes
will have to respond to so
you know you've got the national guard
that gets there they're fighting
wildfires
and they're involved in helping
back back home here with with floods and
other natural disasters so i mean it
does
those kinds of issues do back up on the
national security establishment as you
would think that they that they would
that's why it's important that you know
we completely fund the defense
department they have the capabilities to
help out people just like i talked about
in pakistan a few minutes ago and
certainly uh here at home but we're not
that this country's not immune to the
same sorts of pressures
by climate change and other
infrastructure issues that that that
other countries are all right last
question
thanks um can you talk about the
taiwan policy act that's getting marked
up in the foreign relations committee
tomorrow we know you've had some
problems with it are you working with
democrats on the committee to get that
language changed and what specifically
do you want to see coming out of it that
makes you feel good about
that piece of legislation
members of our legislative team and in
the administration here are
in discussions with with members of
congress
about this proposal legislation i don't
want to get too far ahead of it because
it is proposed legislation but as we do
normally we are working with members of
congress
about about it and as it goes forward
but i would just remind that
we have been
deepening
our involvement and our support for
taiwan in this administration you saw
that just a week or so ago announced
another round of uh arms sales to taiwan
more than a billion dollars will give
them capabilities to deal with the kinds
of threats that they continue to face
certainly from
from the prc so we've been adamant about
being committed to taiwan's self-defense
uh and moving that forward and we look
forward to working with congress on on
this proposed legislation as it as it
works through the process but it is
working through the process
i think that's about as far as i'll go
today
thank you guys appreciate it can you
define where your job is at the white
house
okay thanks john
all right just have one uh a topper for
you we have about 25 minutes before
folks have to gather for the event at 3
o'clock so this afternoon president
biden will be joined by thousands of
americans in celebrating the historic
inflation reduction act here at the
white house the president will highlight
how this historic legislation will
deliver for middle class families and
why it's a major win for them over rich
special interests the president is proud
that this bill delivers on promises that
washington has made to american people
for decades
like lowering costs for families and
finally taking aggressive action to
tackle the climate crisis
in his remarks today the president will
note that while republican members of
congress could have joined in a
bipartisan effort to fight inflation
instead they unanimously opposed
lowering costs for the american people
and they have now unconscionably
doubled down by declaring their top
economic priority is to repeal the
inflation reduction act
think about that
the inflation reduction act has already
led to announcements of new
manufacturing jobs being created in the
united states including from companies
who weren't planning to invest more here
before the law but they want to cancel
those jobs take away those jobs
americans have been forced to pay two to
three times as much as people in other
countries for prescription drugs
for so so long
but republicans want to tie medicare's
hand again
it's flat wrong
the president will also call out
congressional republicans for stopping
us from capping the price of insulin at
thirty five dollars
and that they are going all out to
prevent the irs from stopping rich law
breakers who are taking advantage of
everyone else
now today's cpi data show more progress
in bringing global inflation down here
at home
thanks in part to the president's
actions and the fastest decline in gas
prices in a decade
but there is still more work to do to
bring prices down
which is yet another reason why the
inflation reduction act that the
president that president biden is
speaking about this afternoon is so
critically
important i also want to say a word few
words about the bill that senator graham
just introduced just a couple of hours
ago in the senate
a national ban on abortion which would
strip away women's rights in all 50
states
it's wildly out of step with where the
majority of americans are
today while president biden and vice
president harris are focused on
the historic passage of the inflation
reduction act and taking action to
reduce the cost of prescription drugs
health care and energy
and unprecedented action to address
climate change as well republicans in
congress are focused on taking rights
away from millions millions of women
across the country
while we are fighting for progress they
are fighting to take us back
president biden and congressional
democrats are committed to restoring the
protections of roe and they are
committed to doing so in the face of
continued radical steps by elected
republicans to put personal health care
decisions in the hands of politicians
instead of women and their doctors
which threatens women's health and their
lives
that's what at stake that's what's at
stake right now in this country and the
american people need to use their voices
with that chris you want to take kick us
off uh yes uh how is the white house
preparing for potential strike railroads
um
uh
or there's the capacity through other
means to move goods through the country
uh you know what is being done right now
so let me just first say that it's
important to remember uh that the unions
and and companies are are still at the
table which is uh incredibly incredibly
important they're negotiating in good
faith as the president and cabinet
secretaries have pushed for these past
several months and we have made crystal
clear
to the interested parties the harm that
american families businesses and farmers
and communities would experience if they
were not to reach a resolution a couple
of things i would say
about basically a contingency plan is
what i think you're asking me here is uh
so we are working with other modes of
transportation including the shippers
and truckers air air freight
air freight to see how they can step in
and keep goods moving
in case of of this rail shutdown the
administration has also been working
with relevant agencies to assess what
supply chains and commodities are are
most likely to face severe uh
disruptions and available authorities uh
to keep goods moving so again we're
worked we're really uh working with uh
and trying to figure out with other
modes of transportation how to move
forward president working the phones
himself who has he spoken to so um just
a couple of things on that look the
president has been involved in this and
the cabinet secretaries have been
involved uh since the early days of of
this effort
the administration has made hundreds of
calls
and meetings with unions and companies
since early spring
and will continue to do so the white
house also back in on july 15th they
took a step in creating the presidential
emergency board
and so after a a careful deliberation to
find experienced members who could be
trusted by both sides they formed that
board which provided the framework to
restart negotiations so that was july 15
but they have been
they have been in constant
communications since the early days of
the spring the president yes renault is
personally calling
i'm happy to share that as well yes just
yesterday while he was in boston the
president called both the unions and the
companies to alert
to uh to avert a strike and
again you know as a reminder it is just
a it's just the latest engagement so yes
the president has been engaged as i just
laid out and again
the administration has made hundreds of
calls since early spring and you have
the secretaries of labor involved you
have the secretary of agriculture
involved you have the secretary of
transportation uh have been directly
engaged since the early days last thing
the president plans to pass his ballot
delaware primaries today i don't have
anything to share about that at this
time
okay
on the inflation report that came out
today the president is promising the
inflation reduction act will do just
that and bring down costs but this bill
does not address food or housing prices
of which we are seeing going up so
what is your message to americans who
are seeing these rising costs and are
you confident that you're doing enough
to finally bring these down so look the
president has said for uh some time now
when it comes to his uh his number one
economic priority is to deal with
inflation is to make sure that we are
lowering costs for americans people for
the american people for american
families americans who have to come
around the table uh you know once a
month in particular to figure out how
are they going to pay those bills again
this is why the event that we're having
in less than 45 minutes to celebrate and
talk talk about you'll hear from the
president about the inflation reduction
act is so critical that is why democrats
and this president uh took took the you
know did the hard work to get that done
is to lower costs on health care to
lower cost on prescription drugs
and and also energy costs as well look
when you look at the data the inflation
data
we're seeing more progress bringing
global inflation down in the u.s economy
as i just stated moments ago overall
prices have been essentially flat in our
country these these last two months that
is welcome news for american families
with more work still to do as you know
every day this summer gas prices have
come down
we are at about a dollar have come down
on average a dollar and 30 cents a
gallon that is because of the work that
this administration did with the
leadership
of this president this month we saw some
welcome moderation in the price
increases for food at the grocery store
it's moderating which is important and
real wages are going up again for the
second month in a row giving hard
families hard-working families just a
little bit of breathing room that you
hear the president say
look we understand that there is more
work to do and that is something that we
are uh very very focused on as well the
more work that we have to do to get this
more uh down costs down for for american
families but this bill doesn't address
groceries or rent so how long should
americans expect those prices to remain
high so look we're again we're going to
do everything that we can to lower
prices but let me but we have taken
concrete uh actions to lower food uh for
example there's the doubling cropping
double cropping that usda is making it
easier for u.s farmers to grow food in
america increase food supply and lower
food costs for american families there's
the fertilizer which is also important
in where fertilizer prices spiked
following russia's invasion of ukraine
and remain at high levels that's why the
president took action there and usad
have has committed 500 million dollars
to lower fertilizer costs for farmers
and increased supply there's the ocean
shipping as well the president signed
into law a historic reform of ocean
shipping interesting industry all of
these actions
are going to help lower cost again we
understand that there's more work to do
but we have to understand that the inf
the
inflation reduction act it is a historic
piece of legislation it is going to make
a a big it's going to be a big deal for
families change their lives as you look
at prescription drugs and for medicare
beneficia beneficiaries as you look at
energy cost uh for uh for american
american families that is still a big
deal is there more work to be done
absolutely
back on the real talks is there any
progress being made in these talks green
again we uh as i mentioned the president
uh spoke uh to um to uh to both the
unions and the companies uh yesterday we
have encouraged we continue uh to
encourage both sides uh to continue the
conversation the talks uh at the
negotiation table uh we are encouraged
that they're doing that in good faith
and so again the secretaries that i
mentioned secretary of department of
labor secretary of department of
transportation and agriculture have been
working through this uh since early
spring and we're committed uh to make
sure that uh we get that we we are
helpful here how damaging will a strike
be to the u.s economy which seems to be
in sort of a fragile stage at this point
so look
i mean we're going to be very honest a
shutdown would have a tremendous impact
uh on our supply chains as you all know
it's going to have a ripple
effects into our overall economy
on the american american families a
shutdown is not acceptable that is not
something that we want it risks harming
families it risks farming harming
businesses and whole communities and we
have made that clear empathetically and
repeatedly
to both parties so we are aware of the
impact this might have which is why
again the president put together uh the
peb the board back in july
to make sure that there was a
negotiation framework to make sure there
were neutral arbiters that could help uh
get to a solution here
okay i'm going to try and get around
because i haven't
follow up on this question so that the
president's emergency board didn't just
create a framework it proposed
recommendations recommendations accepted
by 10 of the unions and the companies
the two unions that are talking about
the dispute have not accepted these
recommendations what's the president's
view of those recommendations is he
urging them to accept the
recommendations before friday's deadline
so i'm not going to get ahead of the
conversations that are happening right
now what we are saying is we want to see
continue to see the good faith we
believe that the negotiations the
conversations are happening in good
faith
we want to continue to see that
they are continue to be at the table
and so that's what we're going to
push for at this time the specific issue
is it's a question of the workers rights
to take time off they say that they
should have the right to call in sick
pay respects to their relatives when
they want to take bereavement and
they're not able to do that is the
president's sympathetic to that because
that's the primary issue in here yeah so
as you know the president strongly
supports collective bargaining
as the best process available
for employers and working people to
reach mutual acceptable solutions but
here's the reality and this is what the
president understands which is uh you
know he's focused on how
this is going to hurt families and farms
and businesses and communities that they
could be harmed by this rail shutdown so
so again he encourages them uh to
continue to negotiate at the table in
good faith given the potential risk of
harm is the president prepared to sign a
bill
enacting the recommendations of the
president's emergency board so look you
know
the rail companies we again we have to
remember that they are
and the unions have worked out
agreements in previous negotiations this
is not the first time and they can do
this
again so we are going to encourage them
to stay at the negotiate negotiation
table and uh and in good faith and come
up with the solution this time around as
they have done many times before all
right i'm going to try and go around
uh go ahead way in the back
i'd like to ask you about senator
graham's bill
you just said that this is wildly out of
step with how the american people feel
but throughout the years and even
recently there have been many polls that
show his his bill calls for a 15-week
ban that even amongst people who would
like abortion to be legal when it comes
to bans that 15 weeks 20 weeks 24
um there actually is support for that so
is the white house open to
speaking with senator graham about some
kind of compromise so so two things i
want to say there the first thing is
the senator's proposal would keep in
place the most extreme the most extreme
state-level abortion bans that ban all
abortions and have no exceptions for
health for health rape or incest that's
just what his bill would do and it also
provides no exceptions for women who may
need access to abortion for their health
that's what his bill does it is an
extreme piece of legislation and it is
in line from what we are seeing
from republicans on these extreme
agendas that is not in line that is not
in line with majority of americans one
last thing and then i'll move on i'm
going to quote lindsey graham from
august 7th 2022 and he said
i've been consistent i think states
should decide the issue of marriage and
states should decide the issue of
abortion and so there you know that's
from his own uh his own mouth and now he
wants to do a national ban i'm going to
move around we we actually have 10
minutes or less so i'm going to move
around uh go ahead and then i'll come
back um what exactly would the inflation
reduction act do to reduce inflation in
the short term
so i i when you look at um
the lowering costs in particular uh
for uh for americans i think that's
important when you think about how
inflation uh has uh has increased uh
costs uh for american americans if you
think about the hundred dollar uh saving
about a hundred dollar per year on on
premiums with aca uh when you think
about lowering costs for our seniors
capping that at 2 000 a year instead of
thousands and thousands of dollars a
month that lowering of cost
as we
as we deal with a time
that is a difficult for many many
americans look
experts economist has said themselves uh
that this would uh be uh the inflation
reduction act would um uh uh would would
be beneficial to that 300 extra 300
billion dollars in deficit that is
really important as we have uh right now
1.7 billion uh in deficit deduction
under this administration it would it
would help lower that even even more
which is incredibly important
and so look we've heard from republicans
and democrats uh who were u.s
u.s treasury secretaries who said it
would lower inflation we've heard from
more than 126 economists said it would
lower inflation
and so i think that is uh
that is also an important fact that we
point to uh when we talk about the
importance of the inflation reduction
act the importance of lowering costs for
american more american families even as
you look at the energy costs as well but
some of the
savings that you're pointing to wouldn't
kick in until 2024 or 2026 so is it fair
to suggest to people that somehow
they're going to see some inflation
reduction right now while they're
hurting the votes well that that is
actually not true um uh so just this is
uh just for some folks who who are
watching consumers families and small
businesses owners can head to
cleanenergy.gov as it relates to the
energy
cost component the lowering of cost to
learn more about how they can start
saving money immediately thanks to the
inflation reduction act tax credits and
rebates that is real inflation uh
reduction act credits and rebates
available today include a 30 credit to
cover the cost of insulin installing
rooftop solar up to 10 credit to cover
the cost of insulation materials and
other energy efficient improvements like
energy savings windows and doors a three
hundred dollar tax credit for purchasing
efficient heating and cooling equipment
like a heat pump or central air
conditioner a tax credit of up to seven
seventy five hundred dollars uh for
purchasing a new electric vehicle all of
these things could happen and are
available to folks those rebates uh are
available to folks those tax credits are
available to folks today i'm gonna go
around um
correct okay
thank you okay on title nine thank you
uh the common period
just ended yesterday it was swamped with
comments a lot of people writing in
saying they don't like this it's going
to hurt women it's going to hurt girls
on athletic fields and dorms and locker
rooms
does the administration share those
concerns a and b
if enough people oppose it the revisions
adding gender identity to sexual
orientation will the administration pull
back and drop it so
i would refer you to the department of
of education who would have details here
the more specifics on this but more
broadly speaking
a couple of things for you we certainly
appreciate each of the
com
commentators or commenters if you will
uh for taking the time to share new
views their views about the proposed
amendments uh to the department's uh
title ix regulations uh this is a
critical part of any regulatory agenda
process from hearing from others from
hearing uh the comments that uh that the
americans may have about the process the
department reviews each and every
comment to help inform the development
of the final regulations that's how the
process works and we're not going to
prejudge its process here as we would
not for any regulatory agenda that
happens uh through various agencies just
across the federal government the
promise the promise of title ix remains
as vital today as it has been over its
five decades and the department is
committed to its full and fair
enforcement any more details i would
refer you to the department of education
i'm going to keep going we have just a
few minutes go ahead
while an administration certainly has um
the opportunity to celebrate
achievements like legislation is there
any concern that there's a dissonance
between the current economic moment
and the kind of celebration you'll have
this afternoon on the south lawn about
the inflation reduction act when today's
figures show uh that inflation is still
a great concern when we've talked about
the amtrak situation and so forth is
there a disconnect there so i think if
we look at the picture more broadly
about what this means because we have to
remember the inflation reduction act is
historic
if you think about how
how
electeds
like the president and democrats on
congress other democrats for for decades
have been trying to fight big pharma
have
taken that to head for the last last few
decades to make sure that medicare that
our seniors are able to um to
to not pay thousands of dollars a month
and that is a huge huge historic uh
historic win for the american people uh
it's not about us celebrating it's about
the win for the history for the american
and that's what you've seen when you see
costs that are going to come down for
our seniors when you see costs that are
going to come down for american families
as i just listed out for
energy costs are going to come down when
you think about the health care costs
are going to come down
that is a fight that we have been having
for some time
in washington dc that is a huge a huge
win for the american the american people
we understand and i've said this many
times the president has said this many
times that there's more work to do
but if you look at the
president's economic uh plan just more
broadly you think about the american
rescue plan that helped puts
a few hundred bucks in people's pockets
during one of the most difficult times
uh
in the early early beginnings of the
pandemic
you think about how it helped turn our
economy back on how it helped get shots
and arms how it helped give us a
historic economic economic
growth that we have seen how it helped
create 10 million jobs alone in this
president's administration how it helped
lower unemployment that unemployment to
3.5 percent all of that is part of the
broader economic plan that this
president uh has had you think about the
bipartisan infrastructure law that's
going to create jobs you think about uh
you think about the infrastructure
reduction act that's going to create
jobs bring manufacturing back home so we
can actually create
jobs right here
you know good union paying jobs that is
a huge deal that is what the inflation
reduction act does only part which is
only part of the americans
economic plan
i'm sorry the president's economic plan
so yes we think it's important because
this is a huge win
for the american people and we were able
to beat special interest so that is a
wealthy special interest that is really
important go ahead jenny
ask one more follow-up on the rail
negotiations um
to all steve's good questions one other
thing that the president do is ask
congress to extend the window to
negotiate further since you know you
have a couple days left but if you're
trying to avert a shutdown and
everyone's at the table is the president
open to doing that
look this is again and i've said this
already this is has been done before
these types of negotiations they've gone
through this process and they've come to
a resolution in the past
and that's what we're going to focus on
we're going to make sure we we encourage
folks to stick at the
stick at the negotiation table to come
up with a resolution this is important
this is important because of what this
could mean for the american the american
people what this could mean for american
families again our
our administration
our secretaries have been
have been at this
since early uh since early spring
they've made more than 100 calls as i've
just laid out they've been in regular
communication with both sides and we
encourage them we to please
negotiate in good faith this is
incredibly important and this is why we
have been engaged for the past several
months on this you don't see enough
progress let's say by tomorrow night
is the president open to ex asking
cronus to extend that window or are you
just not getting ahead of me again i'm
just we're going to continue uh to uh
encourage folks to to stay at the
negotiation table in good faith and
that's what the work that we've been
doing the past several months
all right
[Music]
there's so many people so many hands i'm
so sorry it's just hard to
i wanted to ask about something a little
later in the week um the president's
delivering a keynote at the united we
stand summit um i wanted to try to get a
sense of his remarks or what he's going
to say but also i wonder if he's
introducing any initiatives executive
orders there are some critics that say
he needs to do more than just speak out
about hate uh so really quickly just to
give you a bit of a preview uh this week
at the white house as you just mentioned
uh the president's gonna be hosting the
the united we stand summit to counter
the the corrosive effects of hate
motivated violence on our democracy and
public safety the summit will highlight
the response of the biden harris
administration and communities
nationwide to these dangers and put
forward a shared vision for a more
united america
as you know president biden decided to
run for president after the horror of
the hate fueled violence that erupted in
charlottesville back in august
2017 charlottesville virginia and since
taking office his administration has
consistently taken steps to counter hate
motive motivated violence from signing
the bipartisan coven 19 hate crimes act
to releasing the first ever
national strategy for counter countering
domestic terrorism to signing the
bipartisan safer communities act and
most significant legislation in in three
decades to reduce gun violence this
bipartisan summit will highlight
heroes from across america who are
leading historic work in their in their
communities to build bridges and address
hate and division including survivors
and hate-filled violence we know that
even as our nation
has endured a disturbing series of
fueled hate-fueled attacks from oak
creek
to pittsburgh
from el paso to power from atlanta
to buffalo americans remain
overwhelmingly united in their
opposition to such violence we will have
more specifics on deliverables but
wanted to give you a preview of what
that's going to look like again we'll
have more on deliverables for you on
that
um
okay all right we've got it we got to
end this but go ahead okay one more one
more question i know that there's some
criticism about whether the president
will take his limousine to
london and versus other world leaders uh
the the palace has referred everybody to
you guys
what your take is so i look i'm not
gonna comment on details
uh uh
around the the present security we never
do that uh it's not
a good thing to do right this is the
this is the present security uh
and i would refer you to the united
kingdom government
on the border logistics of the queen's
funeral more broadly
what i can share is that the president
has visited the united kingdom twice
since taking office first
to the g7 as you all know some of you
traveled with him
in cornwall and second to cop 26 in
glasgow in the lead up to both of these
visits our team works seamlessly
with with the uk government
our colleagues there to ensure all
presidential travel requires were met
again we look forward to working again
with in close coordination with their
team
but again it just would be inappropriate
for me to comment on the press
we don't we don't do yes or no's here
all right go ahead
the census bureau reported today that
income inequality increased for the
first time since 2011. they didn't have
a reason for that but can you have any
comment on why that might be
particularly when inequality has been
not concerned say that say that
beginning part again i miss the income
inequality
increase for the first time since 2011.
okay i i would have to talk to the
national economic team on that specific
question
okay all right
thank you
um over the weekend the vice president
said that the border is secure but we're
on track to close the fiscal year with
two million encounters breaking last
year's record last month in the last
month alone fentanyl seizures are up 200
percent
uh and we're on pace to break that
record also this year so how is the
border secure so uh
we see record seizures of a fentanyl
at the border so we're actually catching
fentanyl before it enters the country so
that's how
we see that look
as far as the border we're taking
unprecedented action
we had to to fix something that was
broken especially by the the last
administration we've secured record
levels this is what we have been able to
do a funding for the the department of
homeland security remember many
republicans voted against that many of
them who would like to invite me to the
border who have actually voted against
that
we've made over 3 000 arrests as part of
a first of its kind anti-smuggling
campaign we've installed border
technology and set up set up joint
patrols with mexico and guatemala to
catch traffickers we've got mexico to
agree to pay 1.5 billion dollars to
improve border processing and security
through smart proven border management
solutions and the president brought 20
world leaders together to collectively
manage
migration flows across western
hemisphere compare that to the trump
administration which largely just tried
to build a wall an ineffective wall
along the border and couldn't even
finish that in four years
were certainly doing a lot more to
secure the border and could be doing
even more if republicans would stop
their obstruction that's it i'm going to
just take one last i'm i i'm actually
breaking the rule here i'm taking one
last question get it tam um just one
last question very quick follow-up you
probably do not have an answer but uh
will the president be meeting with the
king when he's in the uk and what about
prime minister liz trust i don't have
any anything to share on his schedule
anything further than he will be
attending
the funeral on the 19th and nothing else
to share on his schedule
all right thanks everybody